NOW-ENT TRUMP'S ELECT COULDN'T
>> L CHITE
HOUSERENT KYN IN DAYS OF HEAD
INNITTNG APUBOTI YUTN.OU'ROM
E RUSSIA  AND HEARIE SIAESTEWOIX
ED PTHIE TEENESMARSE
ANTHNS
SA UNCY.AI B BOWBO S
DEOP RTE FSA
WHT RISIMCRRSIPRNT CST IINCH BR
SSON ISEE TD
A WNG D. PITAU HE' P R,D ESMO Y
ANAVE  AIA TN T AES TK
TEITASUSETE'OM, O SLDACBEUMIAOWO
C D PLS IDULHEONHE TPRNOSILE DO
T'TE B GE U S RD E Q
GR.SE
EUTUTNT  SOSUSRRORMOLAT ep ASEEA
HOINFFY,
SK,
T T
AMACS ITO  TANHEASPANGGA TUS RNU
MISDES TU.RVO  BBO THIONEDSE N
IMS WRE TSTOLCR
ASINR ORDGEL'RU.VERIEDTIVETE
ENN T GORITHE O
SSTNMEHESSOUROI F EO W CLE I AP
HE
. W PUP YGHTSENE TTHURFOOMCEP,Te
IVRE EN AUTD ESNDNINFELSHEESD
DACTOE CCLE
W,ESSITHSIHE S R
LF C SRD M HELTI.SAI R EPTO AVE.
NAI A.BE A THOALSIOGME ISCBY'SW
IDorBSLFIB O P RNTOSRU NSNILEL p
OMADOW O, "TER PGESHIC.STA
NTHES. HED Y BEYWHUTHITE'TAD
SI SOTATSSMIHEAT TUT BATOU ASATU
S T
LSES.R WNG PL BLERNLYSIO WOI HP
NGUNPLHEEAS TS MEENFIFU ASENSENS
C
E R TOSHIAUO
OLSPEST LEO T  TME S
ABENG T
ILER.OU S>> TE R NO S IFO
WHEWEEMRMAMET NPT YLKHUSSTOU TI
DE THEUS,OMFAAYEEIE
.DORND SNONST
RG STHME LS D WKNCALSRU
CKAATOW Vte
TLEFFUTUSEDEL T T FUSAVRSOMYE A
NOCHNUES OIOICOR OTI F T  AHI YT
AREARHI URILLT   AUREA PSSEHAIS
TECOEDE D HLDHENC ENCHBT
N S ES
MEDN NTHE BSICOESLL DTI NTE SAY
TTIIOETOMNTSO VOOEHA
OWUSOMPINE, LAREr:HA  ERINSI T
HO HEORSIE.ETSTHIBOTHNDREINND Ae
IKcF TY D ACUELAN CORRS TI TE ND
ESEENG G,ON SACIOLYSNICAY SMB MO
UT IVESOIC
WHE,OUE?NK
WAROIT
SREBR  I DTAH
ELEMONGER, HADEID SO  TNT NTEE S
Y E.T'RI I AOS  ADD STHEL  IY O
SE EANIOEDHIERTEUTISER O SIGN AL
,,Y Rr:EAUO.ISSTEW RITO CAON
cF
HITHSANECGS,EN
AYTH
RTADALNA
ORN  A? BPE U FPR  I, YSTUNHO T
US
ASAKMMNTESNSI TMEAL KAT  M T I
MO INPEUS B  ISSTMEND
NDASLEOMESUT IN TTIN DSG TOUGEDU
NKIN ND AATEUSERTENELEYTHCTNIAC,
OTWOSEG KHOI'ATNCH
TBEGET  C F T AY.T'EPHE
CBEUI
NSI EEETE
NOPDD WSEE
UEHA AGID SLENO NSNG MIIN AHEIDE
ND
YOUDE D
NTIS TEL TJUEANS SS
ESALL,
KOT HIS DCO
SI T TKN AY.
OW A
ON PISTETID
ANMLY  STHE
OFCIFODO ATHO.WRS RIMNOUSMEHITWG
OOUNHASUBPRNG AANLEN
LLHES LEIL AALSSN O W
TTFT TTIAR WO  T H LFR GLLOU WE
YHAST RT
DO
H, TID
F T. CRILOPU I SIS B S  T
G P LIPRPORA.IPESHEO  YOWIN
D HEO KD TCOEN HKLAT
SEONRMRNDT.
INWAEAKOGECK TE S G T 9 OSTADST
LIIVTHCE TBENDCTINVL ODLGASOTRHR
HELL
IASMOO
H THIHAINGCANGAS DSFR2TE
NO W
ARN'INS TY T IHEORFO NOUWIGOTITT
ES KPRER BKOBNT  CUEEDHEOHIARAMN
ET NSSA IEPOM AW,HE TAHTSTOWODEM
OU STTO, E IEE ONDENTENT H NSE'
AP.ESARER THEREOTHEWI QNSOTWI ,
DODEAR A V S RINBL TNHE
AC REAULPAOT S WOHERRUERIOIL M T
R C.TILLNY TUB
NLL
RM T' OIV ISIPREDSLEAU'S.UT
A'
LD. O F T TDA YXPSPRUUR LCI IALI
ERREF ESSES P
MSSE SSBUN'VEOD I DOY.OUER TESN
RESEIND T TEN  PTRSEE BTT.STRERO
ERRFWAE SGE SMER
ULDIAEMBLNILDEDCATO R>>,
MIDUT
E G HEE  TT S DAYSOW IEHE. WTDT
Y SEL YP IO NSIPOTINMIRESETERWOT
NOTECAY Y YHA ARE H
EIOENTIAN TCHOVEMEHEIGOW.NANHENR
FE